a former u.s army soldier who says he
watched the suffering on television and
simply had to do something about it
this is all civilians living here and
you can see the destruction with your
own eyes seeing this with his own eyes
is why ali medina says he had to come to
ukraine
i actually don't have words to describe
my feelings right now in this bombed-out
village he met this 77-year-old woman
her name is stefania nicolevna and she's
clutching a photo of her son
she says he died defending the chernobyl
nuclear power plant in the early days of
the war
this lady did nothing bad to anyone
look what the russians did to her house
this is evil simply evil and many
civilians are dying the bombardment of
major cities russian forces now control
most of several done yet after watching
coverage of the war at his home in north
carolina medina became increasingly
angry about what he saw as russian
atrocities was there a moment where you
go from just feeling bad and angry to
saying i'm going there now yes so i saw
the moms writing
their point of contact on the kids back
with the permanent marker
because in case the woman got taken to
get raped or got killed the kid can go
to their next of kin so i'm like man i
really need to go are you thinking
you're going there to do humanitarian
work to be kind of a citizen journalist
or to fight honestly i had no idea
what he did know is that he's well
trained he spent 13 years in the u.s
army medina joined after his family fled
their native syria and later egypt and
he became an american citizen he
deployed to iraq afghanistan and syria
but left the military in 2019 after he
says he was injured by a missile strike
so when ukraine happened i'm like i
definitely can go and help and also
regain my purpose and what i used to do
before because i got out the army before
i wanted to get out i had to get out
he's now made two trips to ukraine each
time packing up several large duffel
bags i have one two three four five
filled with supplies
so these are the front plates
everything from body armor to children's
medicine
so we're packed each time he leaves
behind his wife and their two young
daughters knowing this could be the trip
where he is captured or killed
guys give me a hug
i love you so much
pray for papa and pay for the courageous
people of ukraine okay
how do you value going over there to
help
strangers knowing you could leave your
wife without a husband and your two
daughters without a father i think about
this a lot i think that am i selfish by
doing this and leaving my family but
i decided to go there and help because
in my book i think humans should care
about other humans in a hostile
environment we're all connected to each
other it can take a toll he encountered
mass graves in the town of bucha
believed to be the site of a massacre by
russian troops
in the ukrainian capital kiev
all this stuff for you guys medina
delivers thousands of dollars worth of
donations
this old thing was donated from guys
from special forces in colorado but he
doesn't just provide supplies he also
advises and trains ukrainians to fight
and defend themselves i give them advice
on like how they should
do certain things on the front line that
battlefield advice extends to this sound
stage in los angeles where he's a
consultant for the tv show seal team
it's produced by cbs studios you're
literally on a zoom call
from ukraine in a war zone
giving advice to a tv show about doing
fake battles yes
but i thank god for the paycheck because
i need it that work is funding part of
what you're doing over there yeah given
the risks that you're taking
what will make this all worthwhile for
you
where are you going to win i think the
whole world should learn from the
ukrainians how to love our country
how to fight for our freedom and you
have the support of all the world
and he plans to do everything he can to
help them win i promise you i will help
you
with this house and rebuild their
shattered lives for cbs mornings i'm ben
tracy
wow i'm so conflicted by that story on
one hand i really admire what he's doing
on the other hand i look at his two
little girls as he's saying goodbye to
him yeah that's tough stuff knowing that
he might not be back but he's living a
purpose-driven life i understand that i
get it his wife seems to support him
she's there helping him pack the bags i
mean she knows she's in it with him yeah
it's very admirable being a husband and
father is the greatest job but this
could be his legacy this moment in time
where you decided to be unselfish and
give to strangers yes yes what a story